the number of coronavirus cases is
rising
faster than we've seen in weeks more
than 56 thousand americans reported
cases yesterday in the u.s
the largest daily increase since
mid-august more than 3 000 of them
are in wisconsin where drivers lined up
in madison waiting for hours to get
tested
is what it was the state's largest one
day number yet
mololenki is in milwaukee where
officials say this is a
very serious problem right now in the
state of wisconsin we are in a bad place
milwaukee mayor tom barrett says
wisconsin's surge in coronavirus
hospitalizations is quote
very dangerous we continue to be in the
top five
in both the per capita number of cases
and the total number of cases
that's not where we want to be at all in
madison this week
high demand for covid tests led to long
lines and wait times
of up to three hours this wisconsin
medical facility says
hundreds of staffers are out sick or in
quarantine
with hospitalizations up about 500
percent
health officials say a perfect storm of
factors is behind the surge
we initially saw the increases in
colleges and universities that certainly
spread well beyond those boundaries
i almost accepted i was going to die
nineteen-year-old alexandria rakowski of
kenosha wisconsin contracted the virus
in april
she spent more than two weeks in the
hospital barely able to breathe
she still suffers from rashes and hair
loss i'm also a musician
i study clarinet and you know i used to
be able to go
for hours no problem now i can go for
about 35 minutes
and i have coughing fits my chest burns
i can't catch my breath
i'm sure you see folks out in the
community out and out in the world who
are maybe disregarding some of the
guidelines what do you think when you
see that
i always say it feels like a slap in the
face it's a lack of empathy
it's heartbreaking
well the governor here in wisconsin has
ordered bars and restaurants to limit
capacity to 25 percent that's down from
50
where it was as health officials say
every single in the
single county in the state is seeing
high levels of cases meanwhile the virus
continues
to impact the nfl for the second
straight week the new england patriots
and the tennessee titans
are delaying their games for a week as
members of both organizations players
and
staff have tested positive for the virus
including
23 in tennessee gail
well muller thank you very much it's
just you guys another reminder that
we are still in the middle of a corona
virus pandemic and you don't know if
you're
you know who has a really bad reaction
we saw that young musician
yes and you can i got something on the
throat oh
cara no it's it's i'm about to happen
young woman as you point out you just
don't know where this is going to hit or
how severely it's going to
yeah there's so much we say this all the
time but there is so much we don't know
about the disease or the long-term
implications from people who even get a
mild case because it lingers
it lingers please be careful people